hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
i bet that most of us out here have had
the experience of
trying to put together a bookshelf or
something like that from ikea
or from wherever some somewhat
complicated piece of furniture or
something to have around the house for
which you get
blueprints instructions as well as
pieces the raw materials right
and so we have a certain paradigm in
mind about how something complicated
like a bookshelf
comes to be there's a blueprint a set of
instructions
there's stuff that we're going to put
together and then some agent us
that does that work it's very natural
then
because we're familiar with that kind of
process to think that
something like that also happens when
you put together a living organism
right when you put together a person or
a whale or a tree
there is some blueprint set of
instructions which presumably is in the
dna
right in the genome of the organism and
then there is
some agents putting them together
presumably the proteins that get their
information from the dna via the rna
and they go off and they build things
and voila you get an organism
so it turns out it's almost not at all
like that pretty much okay
that's some truth to the idea that there
are instructions or information
contained in our dna
that will go into constructing an
organism such as a person
but the actual process by which it
happens is much more nuanced much richer
not quite that simple paradigm we have
in mind of an instruction kit an agent
and some raw materials
and partly that's because you know we
are not intelligently designed right
this whole
system that we have in us of dna genome
uh rna proteins the organs that we have
the cells in our body
this all evolved in a complicated
process and whatever kinds of
dynamics and process was important and
useful
as far as evolution is concerned is what
we ended up using
okay it's not supposed to be code in a
computer where it's carefully commented
or anything like that it's just
what was thrown together and what
eventually got used and as a result of
that
biologists keep finding ways in which
the morphology the shape and the way
things are put together in organisms
comes to be in fun and different ways
than you might expect from the simple
ikea paradigm so our guest today michael
levin is a biologist at tufts university
and it's actually a little bit difficult
to describe what he specializes in
because it's kind of
many different projects that are all
fascinating to me but in the overall
space of talking about how information
and physical dynamics come together to
make
organisms and all their different
functions and things like that
not only does it help us understand the
particular features of organisms that we
know and love
but to someone like me who cares about
emergence
and different levels of description of
reality it's fascinating because we can
start asking questions like
at what point is a decision being made
by an organism or by the processes that
are going into making that organism is
it anything like
a computer is there a separation between
hardware and software what is the role
of memory
what is the role of dynamical processes
all these fun questions
so we're going to be talking about how
cells how information and how organisms
all fit together
uh i'm not sure that i am capable or
qualified to draw a single unified theme
from it
but i think you'll find that it's a
fascinating conversation that touches on
many kinds of things
we've been talking about on mindscape
for quite a while now so let's go
[Music]
michael levin welcome to the mindscape
podcast well thank you so much pleased
to be here
this is an interesting podcast for me to
think about
organizing and talking about because you
do so many different kinds of things and
i finally hit on
a starting point of asking you about
one of the experiments you described in
your papers with the xenopus
tadpole i think that's how you pronounce
it the xenopus
uh you basically if i understand
correctly you and your lab or your
collaborators
rearranged the face of a little baby
frog
tadpole and it somehow nevertheless grew
correctly into the right shape is that
roughly speaking correct
yes that's correct and and i do think
it's a it's a pretty important
experiment and it's one that we can
definitely
uh form uh this conversation around
because it illustrates something very
important so
it used to be thought because all
tadpoles look the same and all frogs
look the same
that basically what the genome could do
is somehow encode
a hard-wired set of movements that would
transform a standard tackle into a
standard frog so the idea would be that
the you know the nostrils the
the eyes the jaws all these things have
to kind of rearrange themselves to
become a frog
and so what we did was start out by
making something we call picasso tackles
where everything is in the wrong place
so legit you know the jaws might be off
to one side the eyes might be on the top
of the head
everything's sort of sort of mixed up
and we can talk about how how we make
those
and then the remarkable thing is that
they largely become
normal frogs so all of these little
pieces
that make up the head and the face will
move in novel
unnatural configurations until they land
in the correct positions to make a frog
face
and so what this is telling us is that
the genetics
in fact gives us a system that's very
good at reducing error
that what it does is continuously work
to sort of reduce the difference the
delta between the configuration you have
now and the configuration that
it in some way remembers as a correct
frog face and that
uh things stop moving and stop
proliferating when that
uh when that error is sufficiently small
yeah which is a remarkable way of
thinking about it because it's probably
not what most people have in mind
well i say most people i mean me you
know not being a biologist myself i mean
i think that
we think of what's packed into our
genome as roughly the equivalent of the
instructions you get from ikea or
something like that right here are some
building blocks
here are the steps you have to take in
order and at the end hopefully you get
the finished product but so you're
saying it's not like that
no it's absolutely not like that and uh
on the one hand
we kind of already know it's not like
that because if you actually
uh and look the the the view that you've
described is definitely the kind of the
mainstream perception that everybody has
and i've given
talks to nine-year-olds in in middle
school and so on and
when i ask them what determines what
comes out of an egg
you know could be a bird a dinosaur a
snake you know what determines the shape
of what comes out of an egg everybody
says the genome
and in a certain sense that's true but
if you actually look at now that we can
read genomes if you actually look at
what's in the genome
you're not going to find anything in
there about the size the shape the type
of symmetry
of the organism that's going to come out
um and and what's important to uh to
realize
is that we currently do not have the
ability to look at a genome
and guess anything about what the shape
of the organism is going to be
now you can cheat and compare it to the
genome of another organism that you do
know what it looks like
but this idea that you can read the
genome and and sort of
understand what the anatomy is going to
be is is not the case
and that is because the genome does have
a recipe but it's not a recipe for shape
it's a recipe for proteins
so what the genome does is uh prescribe
what
protein hardware every cell in your body
gets to have so these are the
the smallest sorts of building blocks
from which
cells build various structures and and
and so it's it's sort of like
you're not getting the the design of the
ikea shelf you're getting a description
of the metal that goes into the screws
and the in the wood or whatever it is
that goes into the other part it's a
it's a description of a very low level
aspect of the system you're actually
interested in
yeah and it's uh would you say we can't
look at the genome and see what the
shape is going to be is that
our fault i mean is it implicit in there
but there's just a lot of steps or
is it really that even in principle you
couldn't look at the genome and figure
out what the animal was going to be
well that's a great question so so let's
think about what we mean by
in principle right so so if you were to
sort of
a laplace kind of simulate all of the
micro interactions
then then certainly you could yeah if
you take into into account
um the environment even things like
let's say turtles which use
external temperature to determine the
sex of the of the offspring you could
figure out what was going to happen
so in a certain molecular sense if you
were to
simply uh absolutely model the the
lowest level of physics
yes it's it's it's in there but we would
like to do something better than that we
would like to understand the encoding
and from that perspective um it's not
our fault
in the sense that that's not what's
encoded there so what's encoded
is not the actual anatomical features
what's encoded are the proteins
and a little bit about the order in
which some of those proteins will appear
as a function of time so from that
perspective
um even though developmental biologists
are are doing a very nice job
trying to understand how all of these
organs come to be it really
is uh a lot we really need to understand
a lot more and you can sort of
an example you might think about is um
the kind of um
bell curve that you get from dropping
marbles into a galton board right like
where does the shape of that
bell curve come from so so in a certain
sense you know at a micro level you
could probably calculate it out and
predict it
maybe if if uh if if if you know the
errors were small enough
but in a larger sense it's that shape is
not encoded
anywhere in the material of the marbles
or the definition of the board or
anything like that it's
it's because what that device is doing
is harnessing particular laws of physics
and so
and and what embryos do uh in in all
living structures do is they
harness the laws of physics and the laws
of computation so this is very important
and so what you get in the genome is uh
the description of a very
uh important and very interesting
machine which is able to
generate and process information
exploiting various laws of physics and
computation
to make certain outcomes and and what's
super cool about it is that
these outcomes are reliable most of the
time so most
acorns give you oak trees and most um
you know fish eggs give you a fish
but actually it's it's way better than
that because it is not only robust
to all kinds of perturbations but it's
actually reprogrammable which i think is
one of the most exciting aspects of it
i guess it's very hard for us to escape
the metaphors that we use to think about
these things like as if there were
blueprints or an instruction manual in
the dna but the reality is more
i guess like you're saying the dna makes
rna the rna makes proteins and
the dna is chosen not because someone
wanted to design something
but just because making these proteins
in this right environment gets us
the morphology the shape that we that
has been selected for by natural
selection yeah this is this is correct
um so natural selection of course
shapes the the proteins that that cells
will use
i think i think a really good analogy
and we can come back to sort of the
status of metaphors in this field
because i think
i think there it's not um quite what
what a lot of people think it is but
let's one one i think useful metaphor
for this is the distinction between
software and hardware
so if you can imagine that that if you
had a bunch of
electric parts you could you could
connect them together
and if they were if they were the right
kind of parts
one of the things you would get would be
an electric circuit that might do
something
and one of the things that might do if
your parts included transistors
is that it might carry out logic
functions and so it might be able to
um carry out certain certain operations
that would be logic
that from which you could build up all
kinds of complex computations
and so now you could ask where the laws
of computation
live that's an interesting question um
certainly right certainly um
you know the the the operations of and
gates and nor the gates and things like
this
were not in the electric parts that um
that you got a specification to
but what's it but but what evolution did
was was shape the parts
and it shapes the parts in a way that
when those parts interact together
they make a circuit and and the part
that we study in my lab is largely
the electrical aspect of it which which
is why i keep coming back to these kind
of electronics analogies
um the amazing thing about these
circuits is that they take advantage of
really interesting laws of physics
having to do with electricity and how
that propagates
and the laws of computation which allows
cells and tissues to make decisions and
to have memory and things like that
and that's that's where you know
evolution really really shines is is to
exploit these these laws of physics
right but the uh i guess that what i'm
trying to
understand better is this idea that
there's no
top-down directing of what's going on in
the individual cells i mean the cells
that
make up uh my liver and my brain
have the same dna in them and they're
they're just doing their
production of proteins and it sort of
all fits together
at the end of the day and it's not that
anyone wrote software to do that right
it's just that uh
the the dna that makes that happen is
the one that gets passed on
well i'll say two things about that so
certainly no one
wrote the software in the sense of some
some sort of designer so so that's for
sure
um but but but i will i will say that um
this issue of top-down control is is
tricky and
and what i'm about to say is is probably
not the mainstream
sort of story of developmental biology
that uh that you'll get from a textbook
but but this is what this is this is how
i say it
if if you look at it it's a multi-scale
problem so if you look at it from the
scale of
individual cells or molecules then it's
that's basically correct they're they're
they uh they are simply following sort
of
local rules about what they're going to
do but i think the evidence is pretty
good now
that there is a larger level of
organization that you can look at
and this larger level of organizations
at the tissue and organ level
is performing some interesting
computations that deforms the possible
action space
for the subunits so what that means is
that it
it basically um alters the space of
what's possible
for the cells and and the molecular
networks to do
so that by simply following very
mechanical rules
the sort of minimization of a free
energy and things like this they end up
doing things
that are in um in in
in line with a global body plan so
you can you can look at things that uh
that that tissues and
and organ level structures are doing
that are very large scale
computations and decision making about
things like hey
is our face patterned correctly do we
have the right number of fingers is the
are the limbs long enough and the
outcome of those computations
are instructions to individual cells to
either proliferate or turn on certain
genes or turn off certain genes
and at that point the cells are just
doing what the chemistry
sort of suggests in the sense that
there's there isn't any magic there
but if you look at the level above
what's happening is that all of those
low-level uh reactions are being
harnessed towards in
a higher level goal that none of the
individual cells are capable of
perceiving so at the
you know at the single cell level
there's no such thing as a as an arm or
an eye or anything like that
um they can't they you know no single
cell can perceive that
but the group agent and so i think
fundamentally this is a problem of
um swarm intelligence and group
cognition the group agent
has a very uh sort of rough um
memories of what the correct pattern
should be in it and it has the ability
to make decisions
about whether or not the current state
is close enough to the target state
and if not adjust behaviors so so i
think i think from that perspective
there is a bit of top-down control and
and we can talk about some of our warm
experiments that tend to show this
um that is not in the sense of a some
sort of rational designer that writes
software but in the
cybernetic sense where there are systems
that reduce
error from a stored set point and so as
long as they can remember what that set
point is
they can then have this kind of
homeostatic cycle that that harnesses
the the parts of the machine towards
the uh the goal which is which is again
you know not something magical but but
but is it is a representative target
state towards which
the whole system tries to get to there
are times when we have a long stretch of
time
ahead of us where we're doing something
but our attention is not completely
absorbed
that's when audible.com and their
audiobook selections can come to your
rescue
i know that i've driven across the
country several times and my favorite
thing to do is to listen to
ancient poems i've listened to the iliad
the odyssey
the anaed beowulf helps make those long
highways in nebraska fly by
if you'd like something a little bit
more modern my own books are on
audible.com i was the one who read
something deeply hidden and the big
picture the other ones read by others so
let that color your choices as an
audible member you get one credit every
month good for any title in the entire
premium selection and those titles are
yours to keep forever in your audible
library
now is the best time to try audible
because with their president's day event
you're getting one of their best offers
of the year
only 9.95 a month for your first six
months
just head to audible.com mindscape
or text mindscape to 500 500
that's audible.com mindscape or text
mindscape to 500500
so is there a sense then in which the
frog
genome literally has uh
the shape that it wants that has encoded
in it
the shape that it wants its body and his
face to have
and then the the large scale
whatever shape it currently has reacts
back against that genome to sort of say
well
what do we do next to move us closer to
that goal is that a right way of
thinking about it
that's that's close that's close i mean
i would say what the genome
encodes is a bunch of parts that when
implemented in parallel
it makes a piece of hardware that has a
very reliable default behavior
that default behavior is a set of
biochemical biomechanical and
bioelectrical
circuits that if if nothing
if nothing weird happens to them by
their normal behavior in their normal
environment
they will generate a set of patterns
that give rise to a standard frog
and so the real outcome you know if you
ask the question of where does a frog
face come from
it's a sort of interplay of the
constraints
uh imposed by the by the genetics which
specifies the machine
and the laws of physics and computation
which which exist around it
now there's a there's an additional
factor as as as it turns out
that this machine has some really
interesting properties it isn't
evolution apparently um doesn't just
favor machines that only have one
outcome
but they favor uh at least in many cases
it favors machines with a
particular uh capability which is
a separation of of hardware from
software what i mean is
it's able to represent different
possible set points
and what the cells know how to do really
well is to build towards the set point
right if the set point changes right you
don't have to rewire the cells i mean
that's a really interesting that that
reprogrammability is a really powerful
uh
aspect of all this i guess this is what
i'm learning not just from this
conversation but from
other uh podcast interviews i did with
carl fristen for example with his um
free energy principle that in i'll make
a grandiose claim and then you can you
can fact check me here
in many ways the way that biological
organisms
work either in sort of day-to-day
dynamics or
or evolution or development of the
organism is
not this sort of laplacian idea that you
give me
exactly the state right now and i will
tell you what direction to move in
it's this almost teleological way of
thinking about things just had david
hague on the podcast and he
he wants to let us talk in teleological
terms it's like
rather than saying if this then that if
this is where we are now here's where we
should go
it's like well here is where we want to
get to
figure out a way to get there yes i i
think that's that's absolutely correct
i think biology has been trapped in this
uh teleophobia
which you know uh is is doing us a a
great disservice i think it's
it's completely not only fine but but
absolutely necessary to talk about those
those those kinds of things and i think
that's exactly what
biological systems do and and we can
talk about how i think
this this aspect of goal directedness
this multi-scale goal directedness
is uh crucial for evolution i think it's
what makes evolution work
it's what makes uh for much greater
evolvability
um and the thing uh i i think i'm
i'm a big fan of fristen's work we've
used it in our own research i think it's
absolutely correct in that
not only do living things have to uh
predict their environment but they
actually have to predict themselves
so living things are a patchwork at
different scales
of systems that cooperate and um
and uh and and sort of compete with each
other and part of all of that is being
able to guess what's going to happen
next and having a preference about what
you'd like to have happen next
and everything is working towards
minimizing that delta from what it
expects
uh and what's actually going to happen
and this is this is uh critical for
uh for evolvability and i think those
kinds of
you know what's important about that
that teleology isn't simply that we
allow it or disallow it
but i think we need to move it from a
philosophical problem which a lot of
people have
sort of argued in a vacuum about whether
it is or is not okay to talk this way or
whether
all models in biology should be framed
in terms of
uh biochemistry and molecules and not
goals and and things like this
i i think it's it's an empirical it's a
very practical problem the question
it's a little like um dan dennett's
intentional stance where
it's very simple you just say what level
of
uh intentionality do i ascribe to my
system
that best gets me to new prediction and
control so
sometimes you'll err on the side of too
much attributing too much agency and
it's sort of wasted and you can you can
do better with a simpler model
and sometimes uh you're you're you know
you're applying
uh simple laws to systems that
internally have a very rich
um uh you know proto-cognitive structure
that you'd be much better off taking
advantage of
and so i've argued that for regenerative
medicine and
just in you know in our lab and others
it's driven a ton of work to
not novel experiments that otherwise
would not have been done
to actually ask what does the system
know what does it expect what are the
preferences what goals is it trying to
achieve
and this is on all scales of
organization
i mean you and i are probably familiar
with the distinction between
in physics newtonian mechanics versus
the principle of least action i noticed
that the principle of least action is
actually
quoted on your web page and it's
interesting because
it's two different ways of
conceptualizing
exactly the same problem and getting
exactly the same answer but from from
very different languages so maybe for
the
people out there who don't hang out on
the wrong street corners and hear about
the principle of least action
why don't you tell us how physicists
think about that because it's clearly
related to what you're saying about
biology
well i i'm i'm probably going to make a
you know a massive
fool of myself here because i'm not a
physicist you you i'm sure are much
better place to uh
to to give a proper definition of it but
um what i
what i understand is that there are uh
lots of
physical systems and and probably all of
them where
one of the things you can do so let's
say uh trying to understand how light is
going to propagate through a
bunch of lenses is you know stacked one
after the other things like that
you know you you could you could go
after the micro details and try to use
maxwell's equations and things like this
to to really uh model every every piece
of it and then eventually you'll crank
through and you'll and you'll get the
answer
apparently it turns out that you could
get the exact same answer with a lot
less effort
if you simply make an assumption that
what the light wants to do is to
minimize
the effort so to speak or the action
that it will take to get there right i
mean that's a rough
that's how that's how i understand these
things and i think that's a that's an
incredibly
um powerful powerful concept because
asking about how much effort does it
take to compute something i think is
really important
because when people especially in in the
biosciences where where
things impact medicine a lot you know
and people say well
everything should be done at the lowest
possible level you say well you don't
really mean the lowest you know you
don't want to talk about quantum foam
but you really want to talk about is
biochemistry right that's
that's how one often when people say to
me yeah you you know you're you gotta
reduce i said nah you don't really mean
that what you mean is you you've picked
a level and that level is biochemistry
and my point is you can't and this is
that people like dennis noble have been
saying this much better than i that you
can't simply pick a level because
because you like it you have to pick the
the best level and how do you know what
the best level is and the best level
is how much effort do i need to put in
to control
the the outcome and in the case of you
know regenerative medicine that outcome
might be
we're going to replace a complex finger
or a hand that's way too complicated for
anybody to
build by by hand from from stem cells or
anything like that
so the question is going to be to what
extent is your system persuadable
there's this you know i visualize this
axis right on the one hand you have
things like
uh cuckoo clocks which are not
persuadable you are you you know if you
want to make a change in the way that
system works
you have to rewire you have to
physically change the hardware there's
no getting around it
and then you have systems way on the
sort of on the right side of that
spectrum which might be humans or they
might be other kinds of
uh advanced cognitive systems where
trying to intervene in their activity on
the molecular scale
is may be possible but realistically you
know the sun's going to burn down before
you figure out
um how to tweak all the all the all the
cells in a person's brain to get this or
that to happen so
so there you're probably better off with
stimuli with experiences with inputs
that
take advantage of the cognitive
structure of the system to convince them
or motivate them or
train them to do various things and then
in between
are all kinds of agents many of which we
know so so animals and and simple ais
and
and and basic life forms and cells and
then all kinds of agents that don't
exist yet i mean i think
one of the fun things to talk about is
the space of possible agents which i
think is going to be actually enormous
in our lifetime
and somewhere on that scale is the
correct way to interact with
everything you come into contact with
and and you really have to ask what is
the
uh what what are the you know are there
goals
that your system is um is trying to
achieve and are you better off
rewriting those goals or motivating the
system than micromanaging it
and i think it's so it seems like
physics is telling you about the law at
the lowest level that this kind of stuff
is already baked in
yeah i mean i can't help but uh talk
about the physics and the least action
just a little bit more because it's
really
uh fascinating to me i mean like we said
there is this way i even did a video on
this
in my uh summer quarantine project
video series called the biggest ideas in
the universe about how you can either be
newtonian and say well i know where i am
now and all the laws of physics tell me
is what to do next
or you can be um i don't know lagrangian
or whatever it's called
uh you can you can say well of all the
histories i could have in the future i
will take the one
that minimizes the certain function
right the action and that latter one
just seems a little magical i mean
you're saying like well how did it know
but you showed that in fact secretly
they're mathematically exactly the same
it's just you know a matter of
convenience but but the convenience is
extreme when you're when you become a
modern particle physicist you're
constantly writing down this action this
this
thing that is the thing you minimize
globally rather than locally
and it's just a much more convenient way
of talking about it
um so i guess the the question that is
obvious to me now is
is there a reason why does it have
something to do with the fact that
biological
organisms are these multi-level systems
where there's collective action from all
of our tiny little cells coming together
is that does that help explain why it is
convenient to talk
in these more global terms rather than
just locally following the action of
every little atom or or molecule or cell
yeah i think well i think there are
there are two two aspects to this um
the the sort of more metaphysical aspect
is
in which i'm not sure how much value
this is but i'll just say it because
it's it's something i've been thinking
about is that if you
ask yourself um you know people let's
say people who are
who are into pan psychism or this idea
that you know sort of some sort of
intentionality is is is everywhere
fundamentally
um one of the problems that people often
have with this is that they scale down
the physical system they say okay now
let's consider a rock or a you know
something like that and then they fail
to scale down
the intentionality that i think i'm
seeing they say well it's ridiculous to
say that iraq has hopes and dreams and
well of course it is so right so what
you need to do is you need to
proportionally scale down the cognition
so
if you ask yourself what would
intentionality or
freedom in the sense of indeterminacy
look like in the simplest possible case
i think what you get is exactly what
particle physics is telling us so
so if you ask you know what what would
freedom look like at the most
minimal kind of instantiation
i think you would you would predict
something that looks like
quantum indeterminacy and if you ask
what does
uh what would goal directedness look
like at this at the simplest possible
layer of reality i think you would get
exactly what these action principles
look like
so um from that perspective um
i think i think it's a it's a it's a
scale and the way i think it scales
is this you know when we when we look at
living things now
all we're seeing are it's a selection
effect all we're seeing
are things that survived the gauntlet
of competition and uh and and and and
selection so
we don't have any objects in in that we
don't see any living forms that are not
good at pursuing goals those things
disappeared very early on
now maybe we'll be able to create some
life that doesn't do that as
as as people work on synthetic um you
know origins of life and synthetic life
and so on
but any sophisticated life that makes it
past
you know the first few the first few
steps of competition is going to be
great at
pursuing uh uh goals in the very simple
sense of
homeostasis so if you so one of the
things that we're working on now is to
try to
understand the scaling of goals from
tiny homeostatic goals
like either chemical reactions that try
to keep uh certain entropic principles
um
in particular ranges or single cells
like bacteria that try to keep metabolic
states in particular ranges how do you
scale goals from these
um very um uh modest
types of goals to something that's much
larger like the goal of having a
properly shaped
uh hand or face with particular or you
know and and then how do you pivot the
whole thing
to from from early organisms that
and in fact still current organisms that
execute goals in morpho space meaning
the the the space of possible anatomical
configurations
and you sort of pivot you run the same
algorithms but now your space is
three-dimensional space
outdoors so now you can run around and
have behavior and have goals that are
hey i'm gonna run this maze because i
remember the structure of the maze and
at the end there's some cheese and
along the way i'm gonna do this and that
so this this idea
you know life has to start out with with
homeostatic loops i don't think there's
any way around it
and those loops scale into progressively
more
impressive goals that uh what's what's
what one way to organize all this to is
to ask yourself
what are the spatio-temporal boundaries
of the goals that any given system could
potentially have so it's it's sort of
like like think of a light cone
so to speak that that says okay here
right in in space and time here is
the boundary of things i can possibly
have goals about so
if you're a goldfish or a tick those
both in space and time
it's rather modest you can only conceive
of things that are right in front of you
and
not too far in the past and you maybe
have a little bit of
uh anticipatory ability but by the time
you get to
um great apes or humans you know you
could have goals that are
that are that are massive in scale and
you know you you just just uh
a huge both both in in terms of time in
terms of memory and anticipation that
you could be
working towards things that are going to
happen long after you're
you know long after you die and things
like that so that's
one way to organize all this is by the
by the scale of the goals that these
systems are capable of
maintaining it can be hard sometimes to
get up the motivation to start
exercising
but once you get going it can be really
thrilling peloton is an easy way to
overcome that barrier to getting started
and staying motivated
once you're there peloton has inspiring
instructors
amazing music endless fitness variety
and an engaging
community whether you're looking for
some extra encouragement structured
workouts or just in the mood to laugh
their instructors are there
to bring out the best during each class
and with epic artist collaborations
and there's specially curated music
whether you're in the mood for some hip
hop
pop country the peloton bike has the
right music to keep you entertained and
motivated
all year long with the all axis
membership you get more like a family
plan for no additional cost you can
bring home the peloton experience
for your whole family with access to
their entire class library
so get started on your peloton journey
go to onepeleton.com to learn more
that's o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-o-n.com
i thought of myself a lot about levels
of description and reality i mean my
book the big picture just talked about
levels a lot and i'll be honest i've
always been very resistant to the idea
of causation acting between levels
downward or upward i i
it seems to me and i think this is just
my fundamental physicist training
kicking in
that levels should be autonomous from
each other and
i mean they can you can derive one from
another maybe but they're they act
differently but
maybe i should just you know uh start
thinking differently when it comes to
biology
or human scale things i mean certainly
the words you're using
seem to indicate to me that you find it
useful
to act to to to speak as if what's
happening on one level like
organism-wide or network-wide or
whatever is
important to take consideration of even
when we're talking about what's
happening on lower levels
yes i think i think that's true um and i
think that
actually there's some you may have seen
this but there's some very interesting
uh
work on this coming out of giulio
tononi's lab and eric hole about
quantifying some of these things so
there's now math uh that that will help
you
understand for a given uh for a given
system
what is the causally most uh potent
level at which to uh to to manipulate it
and
and and you know it's not it's not
practical to compute some of those
things for a lot of real systems that we
care about
but certainly there are there are
techniques that we use all the time in
the lab to
ask what are what is the most
appropriate level at which
um to try to manipulate the system and
inevitably
it bleeds down into the lower levels in
the following sense
so in planaria let's say so we have
these flatworms and they have one head
and one tail and you chop them into
pieces
and each piece knows where the head and
the tail are supposed to go and it
reliably sort of regenerates whatever
whatever is missing
so what we've been able to show is that
this is partly the result
of a of a circuit which is partially
electrical
which stores the pattern of what a
correct planarian is supposed to look
like and
and and we can now see this pattern we
can rewrite it we can
alter it so that so that now the the the
the pattern memory says two heads
instead of one and and then that that's
exactly what cells build
build two-headed flat worms but so if
you look at that i don't wanna go over
this too quickly because
um i know you do this all the time but
this this is just amazing to the rest of
us you can chop off the
tail tail and head of this little worm
and train it to grow back two heads or
two tails instead of one head and one
tail
that's correct um yeah it's an amazing
thing so so there are many you know
planaria
basically i think every every important
question of life is is
is found somewhere in in planarian
biology i i think you could say
um they're an amazing creature uh first
of all they're they're flatworms not
roundworms so they are
bilaterians meaning they are similar to
our ancestors they have a true brain
um most of the same neurotransmitters
that you and i have they're smart they
can learn
but they have this incredible property
you can chop them into pieces the record
i think is something like 275
and every piece will regenerate exactly
what's missing no more no less
and make a perfect tiny little worm now
they are so regenerative that they're
immortal
they don't age there's no such thing as
an old planarian
which means first of all that uh the
worms that we have in our lab are in a
direct physical continuity which with
worms that were here half a billion
years ago i mean that's that's
mind-boggling to think about and also
it's telling us that
in fact it is possible to be a complex
organism
and with with a good brain and so on and
and never die
so so you know these these ideas of like
thermodynamic limits on
aging and so on i i don't think it are
correct but anyway so so so that's
that's what the animal does normally now
um of course
lots of lots of interesting work has
been done on how this works they have a
bunch of stem cells that
uh lots of lots of work has been done on
uh the molecular and genetic networks
that specify
different uh cell types out of these
stem cells but what's
really important to understand is um the
stem cells produce the building blocks
all the different things that you need
to
to make a planarian but you still have
to decide how to arrange all this stuff
and all of it can be arranged in many
different configurations and
um one of the now people learned long
ago to manipulate the lower levels of
the system meaning to get in there and
take
some of the genes that are required for
making heads and tails
uh regulate their expression and get
one-headed or two-headed worms
we found uh something that's i think um
uh uh it takes us to the next level
which is two things first of all
that you can actually uh
that there is a a real-time
bioelectrical circuit that stores an
active uh pattern which you can see
using using special dyes that reveal
electrical states and microscopy you can
actually see this
this uh this this anatomical pattern
towards which the thing is going to
build
and so that's the first thing the second
thing is that you can by turning on and
off
these ion channels which are these
little little protein batteries that
exist in in cell
membranes by turning these things on and
off you can manipulate that circuit and
get the
get pieces to build let's say a
two-headed or a no-headed animal
and one of the one of the most amazing
things about it is that if you then
if you have a two-headed animal and you
re-cut
that animal in plain water so no more
manipulation no more doing anything to
the ion channels
you will once again get a two-headed
worm now this is
the real this is worth pausing here
because what has not been done
in this case is to manipulate the genome
the genome is
has wild-type sequence you've not
altered the genetics at all
it's the this is a great example and
maybe the best example
of the separation of data from machine
in this case because the cells are
standard planarian cells there's nothing
wrong with them that you would identify
on genomic sequencing
and they are happy to build whatever it
is
that is specified in this uh large-scale
pattern memory that is kept by
the tissue electric circuit and if the
electric circuits has two heads
that is in fact what they will build and
so this goes on in perpetuity as far as
we can tell you can keep doing this
we now know how to set it back from two
headed to one headed again there's this
there's a change in the electrical state
that you can make and so this goes back
to your question about um downward
causation because
what what you can you can say is well it
makes a second head
uh what happened to the molecular
pathways well of course the molecular
pathways that are required to build a
head
are all activated on the posterior side
of the of the animal
so you still need all it's not like the
bioelectricity act by itself it's still
you still need all the the the the
building blocks you know the hardware
still has to
make all the cells that create you know
brain tissue and eyes and all of that
but the decision the early on decision
of
what the this tissue level agent is
going to build
is is made at this higher level which
then inevitably filters down
to the lower level so you can track that
lower level you can look at the gene
expression you will see
nothing but chemistry there's no magic
you will see every gene being triggered
by some other gene or something like
that
but if you ask the practical question of
what is the simple what what is the best
way to make a two-headed worm
you've got a couple options you can try
to manipulate these lower level
um these lower level activities and uh
and and it's and it's quite hard or you
can go up to the
uh to the master regulator level and you
can just interact
and this happens roughly between three
and six hours after cutting all
the transcriptional changes happened in
the next 24 hours the first thing after
amputation that that circuit acts
between three and six hours
and it triggers both scaling so that so
that the heads are correctly scaled with
respect to the rest of the worm
and the identity so so of the tissue so
head versus tail
all of that stuff is downstream so um i
you know i do think from from that
perspective i do think there's a kind of
downward causation regardless of some of
the philosophical aspects
in the sense that you simply ask what's
the best control knob
and in some cases it will not be
bioelectricity and in many cases we've
seen that that's exactly
where the decisions are made and i think
that's not surprising look at the way
the
looking at the way the brain works
brains are basically
an elaboration of the system that
evolution found probably around the time
of bacterial biofilms actually
oh you'll have to say more about that
but in what sense uh
did how are you relating bacterial
biofilms to brains
sure um so so actually uh there um
there's a uh there's a lot of work on
some of the early work on ion channels
actually was done
in bacteria it was known uh from uh from
from
you know decades ago that uh bacteria
can be electrically active
and there was some uh some recently some
really nice work from
uh from ucla where there's a set of uh
papers
by arthur prindle um and colleagues
who have shown that bacterial biofilms
drive a lot of very brain-like
electrical dynamics
so individual individual bacteria
coordinate with each other and what you
get are waves
of potassium waves that in many ways are
similar to what happens in brains
and i see basic right and basically
bacterial biofilms you know they're kind
of proto-body right they're
they're they're individual organisms
learning to live with each other
in a way to make a larger agent that can
do things that individual agents can't
good
that is actually very helpful and i'm
sure that's worth the whole podcast by
itself but
i do want to get back to the planarian
there because i am not personally an
expert
on the planarian reproductive strategy
so i don't even know do they lay eggs or
or
give birth but how exactly is the
information about one headed versus
two-headed
planarian uh set downs
uh traveling down to future generations
like where in the organism is it
yeah yeah so so so this is a great
question um a couple of things uh let's
let's start
back with the question of how they
normally reproduce so
uh which which already uh tells us that
we there's a lot we don't know so
so planaria uh is some at least the
species that we work with
they are capable of laying eggs and
producing sperm and sexual reproduction
but
mostly what they do is fission so when
they feel
happy or in fact when they're stressed
either one leads to the same outcome
okay uh so oddly enough um organisms for
human beings too yeah
right yeah lots of lots i mean people
use them actually for um
uh to study uh uh addiction to drug
addiction and
you know they get addicted to all the
same stuff that we do and so on so
when you know when they want a fission
uh the back end
grabs onto the dish the front end keeps
going and they tear themselves in the
middle
and then they regenerate now you've got
two worms so that's their normal
reproductive cycle now
already before we even get to the
two-headed stuff there's something
really interesting here which is that
um you and i uh and and most animals
when we reproduce
our children do not inherit the
mutations that happen to us during our
lifetime so if you get a change of dna
in your arm your kids don't get that
so that is um that's that's really
important
and but but the thing with planaria
because each piece
rebuilds a new body out of the cells
that were in that piece
this means that unlike the rest of us
they practice somatic inheritance
they do inherit every mutation that
doesn't kill the the neoblast to the
stem cell and got it
and those things proliferate so for
let's say 400 million years
they've been accumulating mutations and
you can see this in their
their genomes are an incredible mess we
don't even have a proper
genomic assembly for the kinds of worms
that that we work with
uh they are mixoploid meaning every cell
might have a different number of
chromosomes so you don't even really
know what you're sequencing when you
sequence these things
uh the genome is an incredible mess and
yet
the regeneration the anatomy is rock
solid 100 of the time you cut that thing
into pieces you get normal worms
so this is already telling us that
there's some very interesting room
between the genetics and the anatomy
that we don't understand because the the
genetics can be very messy
and the anatomy is is rock solid so now
let's get to to your next question which
is the two heads so
um if you have a two-headed worm uh the
um
they can they can reproduce by by
fissioning when that happens
generally speaking uh one of the pieces
will end up two-headed and one of the
pieces will end up
one-headed um you can so you can imagine
a scenario where
we take uh some we take some two-headed
worms and we throw them in the charles
river here in boston and sort of at some
point
some scientists in the future come along
and they scoop up some samples and they
they they find some one-headed forms and
some two-headed forms and they say ah
cool a speciation event
let's sequence the genomes and see where
where that happened right and they're
not
going to find anything and the reason is
precisely your question where does the
information live
so we have found so far we've found two
places where that
information lives the in in this strict
uh
two headed there's actually another a
part of this that i haven't mentioned
yet which is called cryptic worms which
i'll talk about in a minute
in the two-headed worms one of the
things that happens
is the uh the molecular um structure of
the cytoskeleton
the thing that um allows
cells especially neurons but all kinds
of cells to know a direction you know
from
from from from from basal to um to
apocalypse and and so on
um this cytoskeleton is actually is
actually carrying a lot of a lot of the
information
and it goes back to a really interesting
experiment which is classical
epigenetics so so now
right right now uh if you say
epigenetics people normally think about
chromatin modifications you know all the
things that can happen to the genome
to market for for future generations
there's an older example which is that
if you take
a um a single cell organism like a
paramecium you know they have these
little hairs that point a particular way
and they swim they wave the little cilia
and they swim
so what somebody did was they took a
glass needle this is an amazing
experiment because these things are tiny
they took a glass needle and they cut a
little square in the uh in the surface
of the power of the of the animal i
don't actually think it was a paramecium
but it was a related thing
and they rotated at 180 degrees and they
put it back this is this is doing this
to a single cell mind you okay
by hand yeah that is pretty interesting
right under the microscope okay
and so what they found is that these
things raise
then give rise to a line of of animals
that all have a little square
looking the wrong way and this was
incredible this was the first
real example of um of epigenetics
because of course they had a wild type
genome and in fact there's a beautiful
line in one of the one of the papers
that says well these these things are
always on the verge of starvation
because
they're trying to use the little cilia
to waft food into their mouths
and and there's a little square that's
of course kicking the food out the wrong
way so they're never quite yet
and he and he says they're always on the
verge of starvation and their
normal genome is powerless to help them
and this is a very powerful point
because
yes the genome has done everything
correctly all the proteins
have uh have been made they have all of
the proteins that it takes to make a
normal structure
but the reason these guys aren't normal
is because the information is being
templated off of the mother cell
so when the mother cell makes a daughter
cell it templates the
that abnormal structure of the
cytoskeleton you know
almost like like a crystal templating um
uh it it it templates it
and and creates an offspring with the
same structure so there's something
like that in planaria where actually
that that
subcellular polarity is being scaled up
from individual cells
to the whole organism and then of course
uh there's the one that
that i think is also increasing
extremely interesting which is the
bioelectric circuit so one of the things
that we can
see is that uh the way that the ion
channels
in plenary have been shaped by evolution
is that they make a circuit that has
memory
and now now engineers of course are
pretty familiar with this it's it's it's
uh it's a really convenient way to make
a memory circuits
as long as you keep powering them you
can have flip-flops and things like this
where
you make a a transient electrical change
and the circuit keeps that change until
you come back and reset it so it's sort
of like
like volatile ram so to speak so so this
electrical circuit there's a there's
another
type of worm that we can make which is
really interesting we call them cryptic
worms
and the thing with cryptic worms is that
they
um they every time you cut them they
toss a coin
and they make a more or less random
although it's a weighted it's a biased
coin but it's more or less a random
uh decision of as to whether they're
going to make one heads or or not
and if they don't what results is again
a cryptic worm
and if they do you get a two-headed worm
that is forever a two-headed worm
these cryptic worms the as far as we can
tell all the molecular
uh aspects are normal but what's
abnormal is the bioelectric pattern that
is stored by their
real-time electric circuit and it is
this pattern that
makes them be this it makes them have
this destabilized anatomy where they're
not quite sure if they should be
one-headed or two-headed
and you can you can manipulate that
electrical pattern and and convert them
back into one-headed worms or into
two-headed worms or or whatever
one of the interesting there's a there's
a paper that um from our lab that's
about to uh about to come out in a few
weeks
that looks at this as uh as a as a
bistable perception problem in the
nervous system so you know when you look
at these things that are like the rabbit
duck illusion right or or the neck or
tube or these kinds of things yeah
so so there's a there's this there's
this ability of nervous systems to exist
in almost
almost a superposition of states where
you're and this is very much
top-down control right because it's
driven in both cases the the photons
the pattern of photons hitting your
retina is exactly the same the reason
that you keep flipping from one to the
other is because you have expectations
in the fristonian sense right you you
you think it's got to be a cube and if
it's so it's going to be facing in or
out
um so so that kind of top down control
in the nervous system
is very similar to what happens in these
electrical circuits
in non-neural cells where there can be
this this bi-stability where there's
kind of two ways to interpret this
electrical information and that's what
that's what the cells do so so i think i
think
and and all of that is not to say that
we've plumbed the depths of this um
there's absolutely more uh open
questions than there are answers so
there may be other
pieces to this puzzle but i feel very
strongly that the question of
where is this information is in part
uh it'll it's it's kept as electrical uh
memory in the electrical circuit
and and partially it's in the um uh
in the in this in the subcellular
architecture of the cells that are
copying
previous architectures when they uh when
they form and we should you know you
might also be interested in the uh
the shifting of wormheads to other
species because you can do that too it's
not you know making multiple
you know making multiple heads of the
same species is one thing
but you can actually again by by
interfering in the normal electrical
electric in the normal electrical
circuit
you can get these cells to build heads
that belong to other species of planaria
150 million years distant with no
genetic change at all
and to go back to put this in the
context of the tadpoles
whose faces we rearranged and they
figured out how to get them back
uh the idea there is a goal in mind as
to what the ultimate face you want
is uh combining that with what we've
just been talking about with the
paramecia and the planaria that means
that wherever this goal is that's not
all by itself encoded in the genome
either
right it's encoded a little bit more
globally exactly
exactly yeah it is absolutely not
directly in the genome i think i think
again the way to think about this
is is go you know our our concept of of
of software running on electrical
devices i think is actually really good
to to um to give us an intuitive
understanding of this
i think what the genome does is encode
a a system that when you turn on the
juice it encodes a set of electrical and
of course there's also biomechanics and
and biochemical signals that are
important but when you turn on the juice
it reliably executes a pattern of
activity there's symmetry breaking
there's amplification there's robustness
meaning if you have some extra potassium
in the in the pond that you're growing
and it's not going to destabilize the
whole thing
there all these important properties
that allow you to spontaneously form a
pattern of activity
in this electric circuit it's like you
know you got a bag of parts that were
specified for you you connect them all
together
you turn on the juice and it does
something and the parts were
fine-tuned over eons to make sure that
what it does by default
is is reliable and adaptive and useful
but then you find an
amazing thing which is that there's
actually uh that the thing is actually
reprogrammable that while it does have a
a default uh mode of behavior that it
will execute every single time
there is in fact a set of stimuli or
experiences that you can give it without
going in and having to rewire it
that will push it into a different
mode in particular what it will do is
what you can do is you can
re-write the part of that electric
circuit that serves as your
homeostatic set point it's like you know
if you had
if you had a thermostat there has to be
uh some physical structure that
encodes the range that this thing is
trying to maintain and you can just go
change that and you don't need to
you know rebuild your thermostat you can
you can change the set point so
it looks like in many cases the
living things have a set point now this
is much more complex than let's say ph
or or
some sort of metabolic level these are
uh anatomical
set points that are that are rough not
to the cell
the scale obviously but a rough
description of what the thing should
look like
and these these um set points are in
many ways
we call them target morphologies it's
the pattern to which the cells are
trying to build and it's
the pattern that once they achieve it
then they stop um
these things are rewritable and once you
rewrite them the cells will build
something different and
what we don't know of course is the
limitations we don't know if cells are a
universal constructor
in the sense that can you make
absolutely anything or
are there constraints you know people
talk about developmental constraints
i'm not 100 sure what that really is or
if there are any constraints
um in the sense that if we knew i i
think we just don't know
the code enough if we if we understood
how to reprogram
uh correctly these uh these target
uh patterns i think we would be looking
at something like an anatomical compiler
you know this is like
our our vision when i talk about what's
the end game for our group you know
when can you give up and go home because
everything's done i think what we're
looking at
is something like an anatomical compiler
that you sit down much like a computer
aided drawing you
basically just draw a picture of a
schematic of the animal or plant that
you want
and if we knew what we were doing the
system would uh decompose that into a
set of stimuli that you would give cells
to get them to build that particular
thing
not because you're going to micromanage
the you know the the you're not going to
3d print
individual stem cell derivatives but
you're going to
rewrite the goal state that the cells
are accessing the cell collective i
should be more precise
the cell collective is accessing to know
what to build and when to stop
the the idea that there's all these
different levels that are interacting
with each other is a very powerful one
and not just because
there are levels with different sort of
levels of course graining if you want
but that there are
right levels in some sense right i mean
this is what you sort of got to
earlier i mean there are there are ways
of describing these complex systems that
just give you an enormously
more powerful handle on what they're
going to do
and one of the one of the issues that
you've talked about you've even it's
even come up a little bit and what we've
already said about the planaria
and the biofilms with the bacteria which
is
at what point do a bunch of either cells
or molecules or whatever
constitute an organism right i mean at
what point are they
are they a self that you can pinpoint
like that's a level of analysis i can
talk about
the morphology and the hopes and dreams
of that little bugger right there
yep yeah yeah i think i think that's a
great that's a great question
and it um there's two aspects to this i
i think that we at least that we focused
on um one of the aspects
is uh how cells come into being
and this is the scale-up of and i think
i think this is both philosophically and
empirically this is
you know one of the most fascinating
problems in science is is the fact that
look all cognitive agents are made of
parts you know
there's no such thing as a as a sort of
this this monadic you know kind of
diamond-like
cognitive thing that's not divisible
right we are a bag of cells
in between our ears and when people when
people say oh
you know what are you talking about
there's this collection of cells has
memory and and goals so well you have
memory and goals right and they say yes
i certainly do
i say well very good because you're a
collection of cells and so um
the question isn't whether cells can
have you know goals and hopes and dreams
that question has been settled we we
you know at least if for no one else but
for yourself you know this is other
minds problem maybe but
but but at least for yourself you know
that's the case and so now the only
remaining question is the scaling
how do you scale up from a collection of
competent agents
to some sort of unified uh single
agent that has uh that has a coherent
integrated itself that is that is larger
than these others right
so so we i actually have a model of this
um of how this
this works although although much work
remains to be done but i have a
beginning model of this
that has to do with these uh really
important
elements called gap junction so these
are things that these are
protosynapses this is what synapses were
before they became modern
modern synapses they're basically think
about um
two they're little proteins that hang
out in the cell surface
that can dot with each other and you can
think about like two submarine hatches
underwater sort of docking and opening
up a path that you can go from cell to
cell
so the interesting thing about that is
that and and and this is these are
these are critical for uh
multicellularity
um they are an important part of
electric circuits because they are
themselves
voltage-gated so not only does the
electrical potential propagate through
these open gap junctions but it actually
controls whether they're open or closed
so that means that this is a a
voltage-gated current conductance which
aka a transistor
and we know that once you have a
transistor you can make almost anything
you make logic gates and so it gives
them memory historicity and so on
so so what's what's really neat about
these things if you imagine two
individual cells coming together and
forming this kind of gap junction
unlike every other kind of cell
signaling so you know cells produce all
kinds of molecules in their in their
enviro you know
they secrete all kinds of molecules and
if you're a cell in the environment you
can receive those molecules
and then you know perfectly well that
they're not yours you know perfectly uh
that they originate from the outside you
can choose to
interpret them or you can think that
they are false
you know that somebody's taking
advantage of you or cooperating or or
competing or whatever
but but something very different happens
when you connect with these electrical
synapses
when you connect with these gap
junctions both cells get access to each
other's
internal milieu this means that things
that happen to one of the cells
very rapidly propagate to the other cell
and
all the metadata as far as who who you
know
what the what the originator of that
information is is stripped
so if something happens to cell a and
there's a calcium flux and that calcium
flux propagates to cell b
it doesn't you know all cell b it sees
is this flux it doesn't know
whether what triggered it happened to it
or to its partner
this this has a couple of really
critical um implications the first
is that it makes lying or cheating
almost impossible
because anything you do right anything
you do to your neighbor is immediately
going to come back to you
so uh if you try to poison your neighbor
in some sort of um uh you know uh
competition
uh you're going to get it too and what
it also means is that it becomes
really difficult to maintain ownership
of individual
thought so so if what you have a bunch
of information molecules that were a
track record of things that happened to
you
and and you know we don't have to think
about complex thinking here we can just
say
there are events that happen that
trigger molecular reactions and these
molecular reactions are
a record that you use to adjust future
behaviors you know all cells do this
so now you're sharing those molecules
and you can no longer tell
which are true memories that you
accumulated and which are false memories
that are
incepted into your cognitive structure
by the fact that they floated in from
your neighbor
so now this erases it's like an amazing
form of of telepathy
so to speak because it merges the minds
of these two cells
into a group agent where they literally
cannot tell
what belongs to what and in that case
that is the origin of this i i would
claim
that is the origin of a simple compound
self it's because you're erasing it's
it's
it's kind of it's kind of cool i mean i
think and again this is far outside my
field but i think there's a lot of
important um quantum computation work as
far as erasures right the fact that
erasing information is critical
i think this is an example of that
erasing this metadata that hey
um here's here's here's a memory that
you know belongs to this
unit over here all of that is gone and
that's that helps create a kind of
uh larger mind so to speak and then of
course of course you know this is a
proto
cognitive sort of thing but you can
imagine the scaling larger and larger
to allow this agent now to have bigger
horizons of those goals that um that i
mentioned
so that you can now contemplate uh
much much much bigger things in both
space and you have the computational
machinery to
remember further back in time and to
anticipate further into the future
now this this kind of thing has a has a
cool implication which is that
he would think that okay if this is uh
the origin of the self
then you have two questions number one
is can it break down and what
how how would it break down and what you
can imagine is imagine that you're a
part of
um part of this this consistency you're
connected to to a bunch of neighbors
you're you're this multicellular kind of
creature
and for whatever reason your gap
junctions get closed you can no longer
hear the electrical signals from your
neighbors
you are um uh you are now sort of
isolated from all this you you no longer
get the the
the the the information input you no
longer get the
the consequences of things you do
directly fed back to you
you could imagine that you would then in
a game theory sense
instead of previously where you're
you're sort of forced to cooperate
and by the way this is very interesting
this is where we're doing now
simulations of prisoners dilemma
where the agents instead of just um
cooperating and defecting they actually
have a new
ability they can merge and once you
merge what you see is that
right it's the to my knowledge it's the
first time that the number of agents in
a prisoner's dilemma is not constant
usually you
define the agents and then you see what
emerges and there's cooperation whatever
but what happens is if you don't if you
don't fix the number to be a constant
and you let agents merge
you find out that well cooperation
doesn't just emerge it's it's inevitable
because
you can't cheat against yourself because
your yourself is now bigger
so uh what happens when this breaks down
you can sort of imagine the consequences
and this is precisely what happens in
cancer
so in cancer what what they've they've
known since the late 70s that one of the
first steps of carcinogenic
transformation is a closure of the gap
junctions
and it wasn't quite clear why and i
think this is exactly what happens
when you as a cell which your identity
was
was smeared out all over this tissue you
were part of this larger
group cognition as soon as you are now
back sure your computational boundary
that that surface from which you're
getting signals is now
shrunk back down to the level of a
signal single cell you basically revert
to your unicellular
ancient past you and this has been borne
out by transcriptomic studies by paul
davies group and others
where you um you now
basically treat the rest of the body as
just environment you you you do what
single cells
always do they go where life is good
they migrate they proliferate as much as
they can
and this is metastasis and so one way to
think about this
as as a cancer is is a breakdown of
multicellularity
um and it and it in fact can be cause it
doesn't have to have a genetic component
it can be caused by a purely
physiological
uh cause we've shown that we can make
metastatic melanoma in perfectly normal
tadpoles by preventing electrical
communication briefly and v cells
uh this is what happens the self
literally shrinks
so going back to your question of you
know how you get the when can you talk
about cells
i think it has to do with the boundaries
of these goals so that as soon as this
cell
uh no longer has a goal of building a
proper you know liver or kidney or
whatever it was doing
all of its goals have now shrunk down to
things that a single cell can understand
which is very simple i'm gonna go down
i'm gonna go i'm gonna follow some uh
some gradients
uh to where where food is more plentiful
and i'm gonna make as many copies of
myself as i possibly can
and this is this is how cells shrink so
you know and of course the the
implications of that are that you ought
to be able to reverse it
which suggests that cancer you it
doesn't just have to be treated by
trying to chase down all these
irrevocably broken cells and killing
them
with some sort of toxin you might be
able to convince them to rejoin the
collective and we've done this in in the
frog model
we've shown that you can use uh either
optogenetics
or drugs or or ion channel mass
expression
to take cells that are expressing really
nasty human oncogenes like krs and
things like that
um and basically just normalize them and
force them artificially to
connect back into this uh into this
group um
group agent and and normalize and go
back to normal morphogenesis
you must know you're exactly describing
the borg collective from star trek right
i mean in
in star trek yeah
it's treated as bad that all these
individuals melt into a single
collective but when we
when it's our cells melting their
individuality to make us we think it's
good
yeah yeah you're absolutely right and
i'm not i'm not big on on on
collectivist
kinds of things in general i think the
key is but i think this is telling us
something important i think what it's
telling us
is that we need to come up with optimal
strategies and these are the sorts of
things i do a lot of work for example
with josh baumgardt at the university of
vermont he's a roboticist computer
scientist
um we we want to work on identifying
optimal policies that uh try to get the
best of both worlds because you see when
you do combine
into this into this collective there are
some good things about it which is which
are that you achieve higher
computational capacity
cooperation is goes through the roof all
of that but of course
the downside is that this collective
agent the goals of the collective agent
might have absolutely nothing to do with
the goals of the individual and so you
know when
when you lose some skin you don't worry
about it and so on and
right and so so this is this is a real
problem and so
um what we need to do is to figure out
now evolution has optimized this in
particular ways that's not to say that
that's
necessarily what we want we need to come
up with optimal
ways to uh to enhance the uh
the the the benefits of this kind of
cooperativity but still
retain the multi-scale nature of it you
see that's
the key is you don't want to lose the um
the agency of the
of the pieces you want to retain it
while reaping the benefits of some of
the larger scale features and
it's hard to say at this point how well
that's going to work but i think that's
a really important
thing to work on in the future does this
whole philosophy help us
either philosophically or practically
when it comes to our ambitions
to go in there and change organisms not
just solve
uh cure diseases but to make new
organisms to do synthetic biology to
create new things from scratch
uh and vice versa does it help us in
what we
would think of usually as robotics or
technology can we learn lessons from the
biological side of things
yeah yeah i think i think absolutely and
there's two ways to there's sort of a
short-term view and a longer-term view
of this the short-term view is that
absolutely so so we work very closely
with with roboticists um
to uh take deep concepts in both
directions on the one hand
take the things that we've learned from
the robustness and intelligence
uh i mean the intelligent problem
solving of of these living forms is
is incredibly high and even organisms
without brains you know this whole focus
on on
kind of like neuromorphic architectures
for ai i think is really a very limiting
uh limiting way to look at it
and so so we we try very hard to export
some of these um concepts
into machine learning into robotics and
and so on multi-scale robotics you know
i gave a talk
called um why robots don't get cancer
you know and this is right
this is this is exactly the problem is
we make devices
where the pieces don't have sub goals
and that's the upshot the good news is
yes no no
no you're not gonna have a robot where
part of it decides to defect and do
something different but on the other
hand the robots aren't very good they're
not they're not
you know very very flexible so um so
part of this we're trying to export and
then
going in the other direction and take uh
interesting concepts from computer
science from cognitive science
um into biology to help us understand
how this works i
i fundamentally think that uh computer
science and biology are not really
different fields i think we are all
studying computation just in different
media
and uh and i do think there's a lot of
opportunity for
for for back and forth but now the other
thing that you mentioned is really
important which is the creation of
novel um novel systems uh
we we are doing some work on um on on
synthetic um synthetic living machines
and and creating
new new life forms by um basically
taking
perfectly normal cells and uh uh giving
them
additional freedom and then and then
some stimulation to to become other
types of organisms
we i think in our in our lifetime i
think uh
we are going to be surrounded by
you know uh darwin had this this phrase
endless forms
most beautiful we i mean i i think the
reality is going to be
a variety of living agents that he
couldn't have even conceived of in the
sense that
um the space and this is something i'm
working on now is to map
out at least the axes of this option
space of all possible
agents because what the bioengineering
is enabling
us to do is to create hybrid um
to to create hybrid agents that are in
part
biological in part electronic um right
the parts are designed parts are evolved
the parts that are evolved might have
been biologically evolved or they might
have been evolved
in a virtual environment using uh
genetic algorithms on the computer
uh all of these combinations and and
this we're going to see everything from
uh household appliances that are run in
part by machine learning
in part by living living brains that are
that are you know sort of being
controllers for various things that we
would like to optimize
um to to to humans and animals that have
various implants that make
allow them to control other devices and
communicate with each other
these you know the space of possible
agents and possible bodies is enormous
um right uh i think that right the
plasticity of cells and the ability
look we we put um eyes eyes on the tails
of tadpoles and
those animals can see perfectly well you
know these
uh the plasticity with which cells can
organize into a
uh into a functional form even though
it's completely different from their
um genomic default is is is massive and
there's a few things important about
that one of the things that's important
about that
is that um and and josh bongard and i
are currently
writing a paper on this it blows up a
lot of the vocabulary that we normally
use
you know people argue about whether
there's a lot of papers arguing that
living things are not machines
well they're certainly not 18th century
machines
but right that's for sure right but but
if you look at what
machines are now you know all of the all
of the kinds of things that people say
well machines are predictable and
they're and they're made by a human and
they're
none of those things are true of
machines anymore and um
with things like what is a robot what is
a uh
what what does it mean to be evolved
what does it mean to be designed you
know if you dig into this question of
what are we actually doing when we
design something and how is that
different from
testing variants over long time space
you know time span um
all of these words like robot program
machine
all of these things i think are
operating on
categories that are no longer good
categories
they served us well in the past when our
engineering was
was primitive and we couldn't make these
um we couldn't fill in the middle of
these continuum between
all of these kinds of things but now we
can and so all of these terms
have to um all of these terms have to be
redefined
to really pick out what's essential
about these terms to really
i think you know sort of carve uh nature
up better than
uh than they used to and that will
will have uh massive implications not
only for
let's say regenerative biology and
biomedicine
and robotics and things like this but
there's there are ethics issues here too
we have to think very hard about um
what we owe to different kinds of agents
with different kinds
of cognitive capacities and you know
i've i've
been in a lot of debates with people
talking about um brain organoids and
human brain organoids and and
what uh you know what human brains are
and so on
because these things are now continua
you know we could
you could now make a system that's 80
human brain cells 20 drosophila cells
and 10
electronics with machine learning is
that a human is it not you know
oh something like you know if your
neighbor got the brain implant
that allowed it to um that allowed him
to mentally run a vacuum cleaner no no
big deal we have people with assistive
devices now and wheelchairs and things
right no problem
and if your other neighbor had a vacuum
cleaner that had some
uh human brain cells that were sort of a
controller and enabled to get around
also no big deal still pretty much a
vacuum cleaner so in those cases you
have you know a 90
10 split and a 1090 split and that's
easy but what about the 50 50 split
then what and so we really have to i
think this idea where
we clearly know what a machine is we
clearly know what
real preferences are as opposed to just
sort of as if um you know algorithm
following by robots
none of these distinctions are as robust
as a lot of people think they are
and the implications for for ethics
are at least as large as they are for
biomedicine and robotics
no i completely agree and i think that
uh you know for example there
people have cared a lot about the
possibility of uploading our brains onto
computers
whereas i suspect that just like you say
blending
the boundary between humans and
computers is going to be
a much nearer term thing that we're
going to have to worry about
in this domain um but the stuff you just
said brings up you know about 12
podcasts worth of of topics to discuss
so we're running out of time here let me
just pick one that i really want to get
to before we go
which is you mention the idea that
robots don't get cancer
and that's very interesting to me
because the thing when i have artificial
intelligence discussions the things that
i always want to bring up is that robots
don't get
bored you know there's no sort of
motivation
or or irritability or desire to come
back to some homeostasis
built in automatically you can try to
build it in but it's not automatic
in an artificial system and what you've
said has given me the initial idea
or the the uh additional idea that maybe
the point is not just that robots don't
get bored but that robots are not
or the way that we currently make robots
they're not made of pieces
that get the get bored right i mean this
is the extra little insight that
real biological organisms are made of
these collections
and the collections you know should be
thought of in quasi-teleological ways as
well
absolutely absolutely and there's this
notion of info taxes where
uh it was you know where everything from
molecular networks up
are in a constant search for information
to update
their ways of representing themselves
and the world in the in
a kind of fristonian um sense um
yeah i i think i think the there is a
really interesting
question about motivations and the fact
that with any living system
we can tell very quickly how to motivate
it we know what it cares
about we know what it likes what it
dislikes because we can we can train it
we you know with positive and negative
reinforcement
uh maybe these things will be a little
harder in the exobiological
arena where we could run across new life
forms but i bet even there
in short order you can figure out what
you could use to to train
this thing with you know what what what
it's going to enjoy and what's going to
be a
punishment with uh there there have been
study
there have been papers dealing with this
issue of motivation and artificial
agents you know you can have an
algorithm that causes this thing to do
a or b but does it really care you know
does alphago really care that it wins
right or not and the so so the the
problem with this question of does it
really care
um like like a lot of problems you start
to see the limitations of our categories
when you think about the chimeric case
so
um i can i can take um cells
out of out of a brain an animal brain or
a human brain and we can
connect them in in culture to some sort
of device that has a machine learning or
whatever
and now if those cells had some sort of
magic intrinsic caring
right that enable human brains to care
about things
does that now carry over to the machine
because this
this new sort of compound organism has
some of that
and what is it about you know can you
take out the human pleasure center and
culture it alone in addition is
you know is is it just uh you know
activated all day long and have you got
like a little little chunk of happiness
there in addition to these but these
kinds of
these kinds of things are really
important these chimeric
constructions uh are really important to
push
to to to to push us to develop better
concepts
because we don't know really what it
means uh
to have intrinsic preferences or how
they might carry over to
hybrid devices um all of that needs
needs a lot of overhaul well i'm looking
forward to our brave new
cyborg future that you've outlined for
us here it's uh certainly
certainly things are changing really
really rapidly and we're not able to uh
really predict where it's going to go
even though
apparently that's what we're supposed to
be doing having a goal and trying to get
there so
mike levin thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast thank you very
much yeah it's been a lot of fun
[Music]
foreign
[Music]